let's go next to our caller from the 724
area code who's calling today from 724
hello david yeah who's this
uh this is carlo from uh pa's 16th
district
um here we have we have a tarot
sorry we have a terrible congressman
his name is mike kelly right and i feel
like
people really underestimate the
importance
of local elections i think you know
people focus way too much on like who's
going to be the president
but you know people don't really see the
importance and the value of
people who are representing you know
their local communities
uh i think that you are right in that
people
tend to particularly in the space of
political hobbyism
and infotainment people tend to spend a
lot more time
following political issues that
may never affect them directly or will
only affect them directly in limited
ways
while ignoring the local issues and
i by no means i'm suggesting anybody
ignore who is their senator or who
is the president but i think the right
advice is understand that
your day-to-day is going to be affected
by your city councilor if you have a
city councilor
the mayor of wherever you live et cetera
and we want to make sure that people
understand that and republicans do
understand this that's
the crazy thing they don't necessarily
make a big deal out of promoting it
they very quietly take over school
boards and city councils and they get it
and we need to get it as well
right and here i mean it's a pretty
conservative
area but we do have someone who is
running against
mike kelly her name is christie genevis
that's gni bus and i'm i'm just here to
reach out to people your audience
that you know get her name out there
please donate to her campaign because
here i mean mike kelly has a horrible
track record horrible voting record
he voted against the like every health
care bill
during this pandemic he voted against
and
he voted against the george floyd
justice and policing act as well
which just unacceptable his
voting record he's voted alongside trump
consistently
so the plan is to get rid of them so i
would just like to get
christie's name out there all right well
people should
i i am not familiar with her but i will
look into it and i appreciate you
bringing it up
right pa 16th district thank you david
all right thank you by the way
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much yes many many races to get involved
in
let's go to our caller from the 407
area code who's calling today from 407.
uh would that be me mr pacman yes who's
this
uh my name's liam i'm calling from 4 to
7.
love it anyways i had a
kind of a my specific question
um i feel a lot of in
a lot of my discussions with more uh
right weaning people or just maybe even
center or even center left
they have a specific sort of commitment
to capitalism because they
sort of um which may call it uh
have a conflation with markets for
whatever reason they
associate the idea of a
capitalism equaling markets when they're
not necessarily the same
thing do you feel like um that's
a big reason as to uh
why people are so adamant uh in your own
interactions with right-wingers
as to why they don't want to uh change
that sort of uh
market system in other words that people
might like markets and they mistakenly
believe
that only in capitalism do markets exist
and thus they think they need to support
capitalism when you could for example
support something like market socialism
exactly because i myself i think that
there's no doubt that
you know the average the average person
probably is not super informed about a
concept like market socialism
i i actually do think that most
people if presented with
the the basic framework of market
socialism which would be
socialized ownership but markets still
exist
i think a lot of people may not know
about it but if they did they still
wouldn't be for it
but i think that we would only know that
if people were aware of it and many
people are not so i don't think your
comment is
without merit
um well that's really the only question
i had uh thank you for your time mr
paxton
all right thank you and please call me
david we don't need to be so formal on
this program